Diane: Thanks for joining us.
I'm Diane Rehm.
Harvard MBA and former Hedge Fund manager,
Salman Khan has become an Internet sensation.
He's the founder of Khan Academy,
a nonprofit organization that provides free online tutorials
on subjects including math, science and history.
Today, his videos attract more than 5,000,000 users a month.
They're used in classrooms around the world.
In a new book, Khan encourages us to rethink our current education system
and offers ways to improve it.
It's titled, The One World Schoolhouse Education Reimagined.
Salman Khan joins me in the studio.
I invite you to be part of the program.
Call us on 800-433-8850.
Send us your email to drshow@wamu.org.
Follow us on Facebook or Twitter.
Good morning to you.
It's good to have you here.
Salman: Honored to be here.
Diane: You know, I saw a piece you did with 60 Minutes.
I was so impressed.
Tell us how all this began.
Salman: It was, as was introduced, in 2004 I was an analyst at Hedge Fund,
not a manager.
Otherwise I would be dressed a little bit better.
Diane: (laughs) I think you look just fine.
Salman: (laughs) Thank you.
I had just gotten married.
I was in Boston and some family was visiting in New Orleans, after the wedding.
In particular my cousin Nadia, who is 12 years old, a very bright young girl.
I was showing her the universities and saying,
"Hey, I think you should go to MIT, major in computer science"
"and eventually turn that into a career at maybe a Hedge Fund."
Her mom actually told me that, "It's nice that you're mentoring Nadia"
"and you're trying to make her go in your footsteps and all of these great things,"
"but she's actually having trouble with mathematics."
I had trouble believing that and I talked to Nadia about it.
I said, "What's going on?"
Diane: What's going on?
Salman: She said, "I took a placement exam and I just don't get unit conversion;"
"ounces to gallons, meters, kilometers, that type of thing."
I told her, "I can see how that can be confusing,"
"but we've had conversations in the last 2 days that are deeper than that"
"and I think that you can overcome that."
I think that she thought this was just a pep talk
and that her cousin didn't really understand that she really didn't get math.
I said, "How about when you go back to New Orleans,"
"everyday after work for me, school for you, we get on the phone."
"It's extra work for you, but if you're up for it, I'm up for it."
"I'm convinced you can do this."
She agreed and so we started working together.
Long story short, the first month was hard,
but once she got into it, she got up to speed, started getting ahead of the curve.
The same girl, who in 6th grade, thought she couldn't get units,
ended up taking calculus her sophomore year in high school.
Then, I started teaching, working with her younger brothers.
Fast forward about 2 years, word had gotten around in the family
that free tutoring was happening and I had this cohort of students.
I had started writing software for them, that was my background.
Giving them problems and see what they knew and what they didn't know,
so that I could make my tutorials more productive.
I was showing this to a friend and I was kind of saying, "This is great."
By this point I had moved out to Silicon Valley in Northern California.
It was difficult now, now that I have 10 or 15 of these kids around the country
that I'm trying to coordinate with.
It was my friend who said, "Why don't you make some of your tutorials on You Tube."
I thought it was a horrible idea.
I said, "You Tube is for cats playing piano, not serious mathematics."
I gave it a shot.
My cousins famously told me they liked me better on You Tube than in person.
I kept going.
It didn't take too long to realize that people who are not my cousins were watching.
Diane: At what point did you decide you could actually quit your work,
quit your job and devote yourself to this kind of creation of tutorials?
Salman: The first video was in 2006.
Diane: Right.
Salman: It wasn't until 2009 that the traffic was getting so large
and I was getting so many letters.
I was having trouble frankly keeping up with all of this as a hobby.
I was even sneaking a few moments in in my day job to tackle some of this.
I sat down with my wife and I set it up as a not-for-profit,
saying, "The mission should be to reach as many people,"
"empower as many people here."
I had never started a not-for-profit before.
I said, "Someone should realize there's a high social return on investment here,"
"an almost infinite social return on investment here."
I quit my job.
My wife and I, we kind of agreed, we have about a year of savings
and that'll be what -
I'll give it a shot.
9 months into it, it started to get a little bit taxing.
I started thinking about updating my resume a bit.
Luckily, we were able to get funding.
Diane: Where?
Salman: The first funding came from, her name is Ann Doerr,
I got a $10,000 donation online.
Actually, she mailed that one.
Before I was getting these $5 and $10 donations from people all over the world,
which was tremendous and it was helping.
I told Ann, "If we were a physical school, you would now have a building named after you."
When she found out that I was living off of savings,
she really stepped up and gave a larger donation,
so that I could support myself with a salary.
Then, a few months later I actually got a text message from Ann.
She was at a conference where Bill Gates was speaking.
She texted me saying, "Bill Gates is on stage right now,"
"telling everyone in the audience that he uses the Khan Academy for his kids,"
"he uses it himself."
That was a exciting and surreal moment.
Diane: Breakthrough moment, I must say.
Then, Bill Gates and the Gates Foundation came through
with a large contribution and then others followed.
Salman: Yeah, they've been our largest funder.
Google, also at that time, kind of stepped out of the woodwork
and gave a significant donation.
There have been several other folks.
A lot of them in kind of the tech world, who have come out to support this.
Diane: How has the whole vision changed since you first began?
Salman: It's been a very organic process,
literally just starting with tutorials for cousins.
As we've grown and even when we got that first funding,
I always imagined Khan Academy of being the supplementary thing.
Like most people, you read news stories
and you become cynical about the system, so to speak,
and I never thought that we would be part of it.
Right from the get go a public school district reached out to us, in California and said,
"We're fascinated by some of the work y'all are doing."
"How would you see this being used in a 5th grade math classroom?"
We said, "These tools, the software, the videos allow every student"
"to work at their own pace."
"It allows the information delivery component of learning"
"to happen whenever a student wants it."
"In our mind, it frees up the classroom to do more interactive things."
In the ideal world, kids would work at their own pace,
teachers would get realtime information about where they all are.
Then, they could use that information to do focus interventions,
to lead projects, to have the students tutor each other.
Within 2 weeks they said, "This is a good idea."
"Let's try it with 4 classrooms."
Since then, they've extended it to every classroom in the district, 5th through 8th grade.
Beyond that it's been 20,000 classrooms around the country.
Diane: Is that in any and all subjects, or just in math?
Salman: The site we have, especially the videos, are fairly broad,
especially in math and science.
They go all the way to college level biology and chemistry.
This pilot that we started with Los Altos,
and this is where a lot of our interactivity is right now,
was in mathematics.
Diane: But, now?
Salman: Now, we're starting to look beyond that.
We've recently launched a computer science on the site,
which shows kind of the creative side of computer science.
Kids create portfolios of their work.
Los Altos in interested now in using that as part of computer science.
This is for elementary school kids to start to learn to program.
Our long-term goal is, as we have more content on the site,
both videos and interactive content,
we think that elements of this can be introduced into almost any subject.
Diane: Do you have family in addition to your wife?
Do you have small children?
Salman: Yes I have a 1-year-old and a 3-year-old.
Diane: Oh my.
Is your wife staying at home with these children
or is she out of the house and working there as well?
Salman: My wife is a physician and she is working 3 days a week.
We also have my mother in law who lives with us.
We have kind of a hybrid solution going on.
Diane: How do you make your income?
Salman: I now get a salary from the Khan Academy.
Diane: That's really fantastic in terms of trying to help other people.
You've done this clearly as a nonprofit.
Are you still offering these videos free of charge?
Salman: Yeah. In 2007, when I was first filling out that paper work for the IRS,
they say admission statement for your not-for-profit.
I said, "Let me think of something."
I thought about it for about 4 minutes and I said,
"A free world-class education for anyone anywhere."
To a certain degree, the free part is part of our mission.
Yes, we intend to always have it to be free.
Which raises the question of, "How are you going to support yourself?"
Obviously, right now, we're foundation and philanthropically supported.
Hopefully, we can figure out ways.
We've already started licensing our content to for-profit companies
who want to use it for other purposes.
We think there are ways that we can keep the mission sacred
and keep it free, so that learning really is, it's an equal playing field.
Diane: Clearly, what you're talking about, the model you've mention,
is sort of flipping the classroom, so that kids can study at home,
do their homework in the classroom.
How does that work?
Salman: To be clear, none of the ides that I talk about are kind of the medal level
or even in the book, are new ideas.
To a large degree, they came to us from teachers or from parents or from students.
In these realy days, 2007, 2008, I started getting letters from teachers
and they started talking about this idea of flipping the classroom.
You've given a lecture on meiosis, you've given a lecture on photosynthesis,
or on factoring a polynomial,
I don't have to use this valuable class time doing that anymore
and doing it at the set pace, some of the kids are lost, some of them are board.
Instead, they can watch your stuff at their own time, at their own pace,
and other resources that are out there.
They come to class time and they can do true problem solving, true interactivity.
Diane: Salman Khan, founder of the Khan Academy, his new book,
The One World Schoolhouse.
Short break, right back.
(orchestra music)
(upbeat music)
Diane: Here's our first email for Salman Khan,
author of the new book titled, The One World Schoolhouse Education Reimagined.
Here's an email from Carol, who says,
"I'm working with a computer savvy inmate and open-minded staff members"
"in a Missouri maximum security prison."
"We put the Khan system on disc, since the Internet is not allowed,"
"and it's now being used in GED classes"
"and being shown throughout the prison on closed circuit TV."
"Is Mr. Khan aware of this happening in other prisons?"
"Does he have any suggestions?"
Salman: That's incredible.
Diane: Isn't that fabulous?
Salman: It's great to hear.
This is how we're discovering things.
As soon as you allow other ways for the knowledge to kind of get out there
and people to interact with it, we discover things like this.
We have heard of other people talk about this idea,
of being able to reach the prison population.
This is great to hear that.
The unfortunate thing is that there is limited or no access to the Internet.
My suggestion would be to figure out a way
to give at least limited access to the Internet,
so that they could benefit from the true interactivity of the site
and they can get kind of the updated information.
Diane: That restriction to the Internet, within prisons, is for a good reason.
What they've done here is to put it on disk and make it happen that way.
I think that's incredible, that you're reaching in that way.
Khan: That's great to hear.
Diane: Here is an email from Justin, who says,
"I've come to rely heavily on Khan Academy for supplementing"
"the public school education of my 2 young children."
"It's the best resource I have found for that purpose."
Salman: These letters, when we hear stuff like that,
that's what, in 2008, when there was some temptation
to turn this into a for-profit company,
it's letters like that that made me realize, at the time,
that we can't ever put any barrier to this information or to this knowledge
and it never be captive to some other motive.
As many Justin's and Carol's out there, the better.
Diane: Haven't some people come along to you and said,
"Sal Khan, you're nuts."
Salman: All the time. (laughs)
Diane: Yeah. I'm sure they do.
Salman: Before Khan Academy too.
Diane: Yeah. I mean, that you haven't turned this into a for-profit education system
and made billions.
Salman: I think there is a -
Sometimes it's well intentioned, especially in Silicon Valley,
people believe that true innovation happens in the for-profit sector,
that only for-profits are lean and nimble and efficient and all of that.
I think that there's a medal level narrative that we're hoping to prove with Khan Academy.
One, we're not-for-profit so that we can deliver this information to people.
There's also a part of me that wants to show people
that a not-for-profit can scale and be lean and be nimble.
One thing that we were worried about when we were starting off is,
okay we're not-for-profit, we have a very great board.
They say, yes, we should definitely pay people, market salaries, etcetera,
but we're not going to be able to give stock options,
because there's no stock.
No one owns Khan Academy.
We're like, "Will we be able to compete in Silicon Valley for the best talent,"
"the best software engineering talent, without options?"
The answer has been a resounding yes.
In fact, we've been able to get some of the very best talent.
Google's first employee, Craig Silverstein, is on our team.
We have one of Facebook's, one of their great engineers.
She was also rated the best engineer at Yahoo at one time.
She's on our team.
We have folks who are really the leaders in their respective fields,
all wanting to join our team.
There was a research study that came out a couple of years ago
that said, "People actually aren't driven by money."
"In fact, the way that they get the most productive is,"
"they should have enough that they're not worried about money;"
"they can pay their mortgage and they can send their kids to college,"
"but they need intellectually challenging work and they need a mission."
It's funny, when I first read that when I was a Hedge Fund analyst,
I was a little skeptical of that.
Really, they don't want huge bonuses?
One, that's true for myself.
I'm very happy doing what I'm doing,
but it seems like it's true also for the best talent out there.
Diane: How many employees do you now have?
Salman: We're now 36 and it's been a pretty rapid growth curve.
This time last year we were 13.
This time 2 years ago we were 1.
Diane: How do the employees work?
How does the share of work get divided?
Are some pure technical, on the technical side and some on the vocational side?
How do you do it?
Salman: On one level we are running a large scale Internet piece of software,
with 7,000,000 users a month now.
They've done close to a 3/4's of a billion problems on our site.
We have a pretty deep engineering diametric.
2/3's of our team are software engineers and designers.
The other 3rd of our team is some combination of content producers.
There's myself and I still produce content.
We've brought some other people on.
We have art history content that's made by some pretty incredible professors.
We have a team that interfaces with schools, interfaces with teachers.
We have some teachers on staff that are advising us,
helping us curate content.
We have kind of a research team that's looking at the data
and figuring out, how can we improve the content.
They're also looking at the literature out there
and seeing what type of research can we leverage to make our offering better.
Diane: Each of your tutorials is just 10 minutes long.
Why is gravity such an issue?
Salman: It's one of these things designed by hindsight.
When I started doing this, I think the first video
I made for my cousins in 2006 might have been -
Diane: For Nadia.
Salman: For Nadia and at this point there were several others.
It was about 16 minutes.
I tried to upload it to You Tube and I got rejected,
because You Tube, at the time, for a regular account,
would only give you 10 minutes for each video.
I said, "Well, I guess I have to redo this thing."
I redid those.
I think it was 9 1/2 minutes and I uploaded it.
I did all the videos in that.
You can cover a lot, because you can do as many videos as you like.
One, I got feedback from a lot of people
that this is working for them, it allows them to pay attention.
Then, I got researchers coming out of the woodworks saying,
"You must have read, study X, Y and Z, and I cite a lot of them in the book,
that actually showed that there's no reason to give a lecture more than 10, 15 minutes,
because people can't pay attention, especially when it's deep content.
They can do it for 10, 15 minutes, then they need to kind of step out,
engage with the content, do a little practice or whatever else,
then maybe step back in and they have - their attention is recharged.
In hindsight, it actually is backed up by how the brain works.
Diane: You know - pardon me - I have often said that when I go to church
11 minutes in and my head is elsewhere after that.
I think you've hit it exactly right.
I think our listeners should know that you come from very humble roots.
You were raised by your mother who is from Bangladesh.
You attended public schools growing up.
How did your background shape you?
Salman: It's hard to say.
I think, definitely, one thing I cite is my older sister was a very strong student.
She was 3 years older and I think that -
When you enter a class and they already thought highly of your sister 3 years ago,
even if you're a little mediocre, they kind of expect you to step up a little bit.
I was definitely a beneficiary of that.
I went to public schools in Louisiana.
I think the schools I went to, they were kind of the -
I would call them probably the 50 percentile American school,
just kind of the traditional school.
I had teachers across the spectrum,
but I had some incredible teachers early on.
I think frankly because my sister kind of blazed this trail,
I was able to get into these GT programs where -
A lot of what I talk in the book was motivated by,
I remember Ms, Roucelle, the first time I entered the GT, I think it was 4th grade.
The rest of your curriculum is this Prussian model,
where all the students are being moved together
and you're getting a lecture and you have these tests and these grades.
Then all of the sudden, once a day I would be going to this GT class
and Ms. Roucelle would say, "What do you want to work on?"
I was like, "She's asking me. I'm 9 years old. What do I want to work on?"
"All right," I said, "I like to draw."
She was like, "Okay, we're going to draw then."
She would push me.
She would say, "Here's pen and ink, here's pastels, see what you can do here."
"What else do you like to do?"
I said, "I like puzzles."
She would say, "Here's some puzzles."
She would push me and allow me to go at my own pace
and give room for my creativity.
I can't understate how important I think that was.
I think probably a lot of the ideas in the book, in hindsight are,
can we get that at scale, can we get that type of interaction,
shouldn't all classroom activity be what I got to do at Ms. Roucelle.
Actually, Ms. Krauss was the other GT teacher at that time.
I think now that there's other ways to deliver the lecture
and hopefully better ways.
There's other ways to do a lot of the problem solving.
Every student should have that experience,
where they go to class and they get that personal attention.
They get personal attention, not just with their teachers,
but also with their peers.
Right now, you go into a classroom K-12 or in college,
in K-12 there might be 30 people in the room,
in college it might be 300.
You're in the room together, often for the whole year,
you don't know anybody.
You don't get to talk.
Maybe you know the 2 people who you sit next to.
It's actually very dehumanizing to be in a room and not know the people in the room.
What we say is, "No, let's remove that lecture."
"There's no good reason, especially a 300 person lecture,
and use all of that for interactivity, use all of that for peer to peer learning,
use all of that for interacting with the professor.
Diane: Are you as worried as some people are, educators, in this country
about what has happened to our students?
Salman: I won't say that I'm not worried.
One should never be complacent about something as important as education.
With that said, I think some of the concern is misguided.
What people always cite is where we are on these test scores relative to other countries
and Estonia is beating us, their algebra students
can factor polynomials better than ours.
That's worth looking at.
I think and I've heard people say,
"How can we be more like Singapore, how can we be more like Finland,"
"be more like South Korea."
I take a completely different view on it.
If you look at the U.S. holistically, 50 years ago,
and there still is innovation happening all the world,
but the U.S. was a significant chunk of it,
but it was happening in Europe, Japan and everywhere.
You look now, the innovation has gotten even more concentrated in the U.S.
We were worried about Sony.
I mean, Sony is still a great company,
but now Apple is owning consumer electronics.
You have the Googles, the Facebooks, all of the innovative,
the Twitters, they're all getting created in this culture, in America.
It's because we have a culture of entrepreneurship,
we have a culture of innovation,
we have a culture of not caring what family you're from,
but really what you can do.
A culture of taking risk and failure is acceptable.
A culture of creativity.
I actually think the task is not how do we get our school system
to emulate the Prussian model as implemented in Singapore or Finland,
it's how do we break the Prussian model and make it more American,
so that we can have creativity in the class time,
so that all of these things that make America a great engine of innovation
are actually happening in the classroom as well.
Diane: Salmon Khan, his knew book is titled, The One World Schoolhouse Education Reimagined.
You're listening to the Diane Rehm Show.
Salman, look at the dropout rate.
Look at the number of young people who are so turned off
by what's happening in the classroom that some have predicted
that eventually the U.S. is going to have only a small portion
of the population, able to create these new systems to move the country forward.
How do we close that education gap?
Salman: I think you hit the nail on the head.
That is the main issue.
The U.S. won't lose it's dominance or it's innovation,
but who gets to participate in that -
00:26:39,980 --> 00:26:39,878
Diane: Right.
Salman: - in that question.
That's why, and I keep hitting on it in the book,
we have this model where we group students in this kind of factory,
we group them in these age based cohorts.
We push them along and we have a set time and pace
when they're supposed to learn certain things.
Week 3 in algebra course, we're covering quadratics.
The information is delivered, some homework happens
and then there's a test.
Some students get an A, some get a B, some get a C, some even fail the exam.
Even though we've identified these gaps in the knowledge
I mean, some students failed the exam because of the way the system is architected
we push them all forward.
Somehow expecting the student who got the C or the D or the F in basic concept
to now be able to comprehend the next one.
Essentially, whenever you have everyone - the delivery happening at a set pace,
it's really just a filtering process.
Imagine a factory line.
The factory line is moving at a set pace.
It doesn't matter if there are defects emerging.
A good factory would go and fix the defects.
In this factory line, you keep moving along.
At different points you're like,
"Hey that's getting a little defective. Let's put it on a different line."
That's not going to be a high-end product.
That's going to be a low product.
It's a whole filtering process.
In the end you will only end up with 5% of people
who can really participate in kind of the innovation economy.
What we're saying is, that makes no sense,
especially in a world where we need so many people who are creative,
who are active problem solvers.
We need to do it the other way around.
Instead of being variable, what your grade is and being fixed when you learn it,
we need to make variable when and how you learn it,
spend as much time as you need to.
What's fixed is, you master the concept.
It's much more important to have mastery of algebra,
than to have a superficial understanding of algebra
and then a superficial understanding of geometry
and then a very superficial understanding of trigonometry
and barely getting through calculus.
Once you really understand algebra, then the rest of it will seem intuitive.
Diane: If you're at home looking at this tutorial,
say you've had to watch 2 or 3 times and you still don't quite get it,
then what happens?
Salman: This is something that we're constantly trying to address.
Frankly, this is why we think there is always -
the human element will always be very important.
We're trying to address it virtually.
Hopefully there's multiple tutorials on that same topic.
We're exploring getting other people involved.
My style might work for a lot of people,
but maybe it doesn't gel with other people.
We get other people there.
There's a community of learners on the site.
People can ask questions.
"I just don't get this. What else should I look at?"
People will either answer it in text,
or they'll send a link to another, maybe, video on You Tube some place
or Wikipedia article, to help explain it.
The real ideal, I have young children
and I want them to have access to a physical school.
What this would do is set up the question.
If the student can't get an answer in any of these initial lines of attack,
then they can go to school and that's what the classroom is about.
It's not about lecture.
It's about, "Teacher, I have this question" or "Friend, I have this question."
Obviously, then the friend can help them.
Also, the process of explaining the answer allows that friend to get it much deeper.
Diane: Have you yet had an opportunity to talk
with the current Secretary of Education, Arne Duncan?
Salman: We have.
It's been a bit surreal for me.
A couple of months ago he Tweeted that he uses Kahn Academy
or someone Tweeted that Arne Duncan uses Khan Academy
with his own children.
Then, more recently, he visited the office
with several other officials with the department of education.
Yeah, a great guy.
I think he really understands the things at a holistic level.
I hope we can kind of tackle things along side them.
Diane: Salman Khan is the founder of the Khan Academy.
He's now written a book about his concept
and the ways in which he's putting it into being.
The book is titled The One World Schoolhouse.
Stay with us.
(orchestra music)
Male voice: National broadcast of the Diane Rehm show
is made possible in part by CSX.
Transporting 2,000,000,000 pounds of goods to market, by train,
and working to help move the economy forward.
CSX, how tomorrow moves.
By Constant Contact, committed to helping small businesses
and non-profits stay connected to customers, using email marketing.
Learn more at constantcontact.com.
And, by Novo Nordisk.
For nearly 90 years committed to innovation and diabetes care.
Learn more at novonordisk-us.com.
This is NRP.
Diane: On the next Diane Rehm Show,
50 years ago the Roman Catholic Church sought to modernize
by promoting activism, freedom of conscious and a respect for all religions.
The Legacy of Vatican II.
(soft music)
Male voice: Phil, Phil Conners.
Phil Conners, I thought that was you.
Male voice: Hi. How are you doing?
Thanks for watching.
Male voice: Hey, hey.
Female: Character actor Stephen Tobolowsky was Bill Murray's
annoying high school friend in Groundhog Day.
He's also had recurring roles in Heros, Deadwood, Californication and Glee.
We'll talk with Tobolowsky about his new memoir on the next Fresh Air.
(upbeat music)
Diane: We're back with Salman Khan, founder of The Khan Academy.
During the break I was asking just how far
you think you can take this concept.
You start, perhaps in elementary school.
Do you think you can take it to law school, to medical school, what?
Salman: Yeah, we already have, especially and the video side
and we hope of the interactive side soon,
we already have content, I would say, at the university level
in the sciences and mathematics, in art history.
We're already starting to work at some graduate level topics.
We have a gentleman, Rishi Desai, who is a medical doctor,
starting to cover the first 2 years of medical school.
On Khan Academy, we've been working with Stanford Medical School,
thinking about how they can release more content in this way.
Our general sense is, we think almost anything can be covered like this
and not just a graduate level.
We can even go to lifelong learning topics.
Diane: Okay. Let me understand something.
Stanford University gets involved and they have students paying tution
to go to medical school.
If they then use Khan Academy, how do they make up for the loss of tuition,
or do they become the for-profit part of your nonprofit institution?
Salman: Stanford is also a not-for-profit.
They charge a lot of tuition.
Diane: Yeah, you bet.
Salman: No one owns Stanford University.
It's not a company.
I think they understand what this is about.
This isn't about virtual replacing physical.
This is about virtual being used as a tool to make physical more powerful.
They've already recognized.
They've actually been videotaping a lot of their lectures for several years now.
A lot of their students prefer to watch that at their own time and pace.
They're like, "Why are we even going through this exercise?"
"Let's make really good lectures, make them interactive,"
"put them in these nuggets, so that they're easier to digest.'
"Embed interactive exercises with them."
When the students get together in the class, with the professors,
with the TA's, they can do something higher order.
They can look at a case study.
They can have a conversation about cases, they can do a lab,
they can do a project.
In their mind, it allows the physical experience to become more valid,
in my mind as well.
They leverage the technology.
They're not getting replaced by it.
Diane: You mentioned continuing education.
There's a email from Dan, who says,
"Thank you Salman for helping me with statistics."
"Your method of teaching a complicated subject is greatly appreciated"
"to a returning student."
"I love your drawings with many colors."
"I love your voice, it's sincere."
"I love your motivating style."
Dan identifies himself as a returning student at 60.
Salman: Oh! That's great to hear.
Diane: Isn't that wonderful?
All right, let's open the phones.
First, to Wichita, Kansas and to Cynthia.
Good morning to you.
Cynthia: Good morning, Diane.
You sound wonderful.
Diane: Thank you.
Cynthia: My question is, I'm 54 and I'm unemployed,
but I still like to mess with my brain and keep it ticking.
I'm just one of those persons that was lucky she got passed through high school.
I was wondering if Mr. Khan is thinking about helping people like this,
that don't go to school or can't go to college because we can't afford it
and we're in our late 50s.
Is there a program that we can get on and kind of relearn?
Salman: Yeah, absolutely.
Everything that we're talking about, even in our organization,
we never talk about - We're careful about students.
We say students of all ages.
A lot of people are surprised.
Obviously, there's a lot of high school and college students using us,
but there's a lot of people well into adulthood,
who are using us to understand academic topics,
or understand things; what it a financial crisis or how does a bank work
or what's a credit default swap and things like that.
The simple answer, Cynthia, is yeah, absolutely.
I think the site, you would enjoy it as it is.
One thing that we are exploring is,
if there are sites like Khan Academy, that can do the learning part for free,
how do people prove that they've learned it.
Then, they can take that into the market place and show an employee,
"Look, I'm just as sharp as the 22-year-old who just graduated from a good university.
We are exploring that, some ways to give what I would call micro -
Diane: Some kind of certificate.
Salman: Yeah, and making it valuable.
Diane: Yeah.
Salman: There are some programs.
Some of these MIT Harvard have launched this edX initiative
where they are giving certificates.
Actually Cynthia, I would encourage you to look at them as well.
We want to look at that as well.
The education is several things.
It's definitely learning, that's the biggest part.
There's a community aspect to it,
but then there's a credentialing aspect to it.
We want to enable you to learn, but also prove to the market place
that you can contribute.
Diane: How does she get to the Khan Academy?
Salman: It's just khanacademy.org.
Diane: .org, and then you move around?
Salman: Yeah. People can search for the content.
If they know what they're looking for, they can go by topic.
They can start practicing the interactive exercises
and that will work them through.
Start 1 + 1 and they'll just keep going
as they progress to trigonometry or calculus.
Diane: Fantastic.
Salman: There's computer science that students can work on.
Diane: All right, to Rochester, New York.
Good morning Wilma.
Wilma: Good morning.
You covered a lot of what I was going to talk about.
I find this so exciting.
Some parents, when they look at their newborn,
they ask that question, "Are you the one?"
I think your parents must be saying, "Absolutely yes, you are the one."
Salman: You're making a brown man blush.
Diane: (laughs) That's wonderful.
Thanks for your call, Wilma.
Let's go to Lewisville, Texas.
Good Morning, Bret.
Bret: Good morning, Diane.
This is a great show.
I really appreciate you doing it.
Diane: Thank you.
Bret: Khan, I've got to tell you, you have really helped my nephew, tremendously.
I recommended his site to you when he was trying to get -
He's still trying to get his GED,
but he was actually getting a lot of help he could get before.
That's a huge thing.
I was curious if you are putting forth any effort to educate people
as to the education system that we have now
that has this over reliance on testing.
If you've put any effort into that
or if you're just focusing on the Khan Academy?
Salman: That's a great question, Bret.
It's wonderful to hear about your nephew.
There's a chapter in the book where I talk about testing.
I think testing will always exist to some degree,
but I think over alliance is the right word.
Tests only measure what they test.
I think what's exciting about what we're doing or hopefully doing
or at least bringing up in a conversation,
is what are other ways of measuring or evaluating subjective and objective.
One thing that I talk a great deal about when I talk to people,
is test measure one thing, can we measure perseverance.
In a traditional test, you can't.
On something like Khan Academy, you can.
We can see how the student it engaging with the site.
We can give that feedback to teachers.
We can cater the content for different types of learners in different ways.
Can we measure people, instead of these numeric test,
also with a portfolio of creative works.
To a large degree, when we hire people at Khan Academy,
yeah test scores are nice and grades are nice and degrees are nice,
but we say, "What have you created? Show us your creations."
"Tell us how you thought about those creations."
That is at least or far more important than test.
The other dimension that I think it completely lost right now,
is how much do you contribute and how capable are you contributing
to improving the learning of those around you.
One thing I talk a lot about in the book and we try to foster on the site
and we're seeing a lot in the classrooms that are using this,
is students helping each other and evaluating each other,
saying, "That was really great. They really helped me."
I hope in the kind of college transcript of the future, yes they'll be a few test scores,
maybe you'll take these micro credentials that we were talking about,
to show that you've mastered algebra and you've retained that knowledge.
You would also have an evaluation,
"Wow! You've really contributed to other people's learning"
"and you have this really great portfolio of creative works."
Diane: Here is an email from R. John.
He says, "How does the Khan Academy teach and grade good writing?"
Salman: That's a great question.
Right now, we don't tackle writing.
On the video side we tackle a few of the humanities, especially on art history
and we have a little bit on history.
We hope to do a lot more.
I'll tell you how we're envisioning tackling writing
and I'll start with how we're tackling computer science, which might seem strange.
Our computer science, we're tackling it as a creative field, which it is.
Students can go there.
They can create their programs, interact with it.
They have a little canvas where they see what they've created.
Then, they can share it.
That's an important point.
When they share it on their portfolio,
then other users can look at their work,
they can comment on it, they can rate their work.
They can take that and then make it their own.
We think the same analogy can apply with writing.
You go, there's projects on Khan Academy, write your opinion about this
or write a novel, write a short story.
You put it out there, it goes into your portfolio.
Instead of getting graded, oh you got a B+,
and then that's kind of a value statement on your intelligence or something -
Diane: Or somebody else's ...
Salman: Exactly.
Diane: ... interpretation of your intelligence.
Salman: Other people will comment on it, give it feedback
and you can continuously improve it, so that it becomes part of your portfolio.
In order to get feedback from other people,
you will also give feedback.
By just critically looking at other people's work,
that will also hopefully make you a better writer.
I think we can tackle some of the building blocks of writing,
whether it's vocabulary and grammar,
in a way that we're tackling some of the building blocks of mathematics.
Diane: To Easton, Maryland.
Good morning, Rebecca.
Rebecca: Good morning.
Thanks for taking my call.
Diane: Sure.
Rebecca: I just wanted to bring in the homeschooling perspective,
because I homeschool my 2 children, who are in 5th and 3rd grade, perspectively.
We absolutely love The Khan Academy as a resource
for those 10 to 12 minutes snipits, especially for math and science.
They really kind of hit the lesson home.
It's just a great resource for homeschoolers,
because it's -
I don't have all of the same -
We'll, right now I'm fine with 3rd and 5th grade,
but connected to experts who know what they're talking about
and can really help a lot.
I think it's a great resource and I really appreciate it.
Salman: That's incredible to hear, Rebecca.
I think our whole team gets motivated when we hear stories like this.
The homeschooling is interesting.
When I started all of this, I didn't even think about it.
It's completely obvious that this hopefully is a valuable tool for homeschoolers.
I think what's really interesting about homerschoolers,
is they've kind of brought back a lot of -
The book is called One World Schoolhouse, there's a play on one-room school house.
There were some really strong advantages there.
This idea of a more personalized attention, a lot more interactivity,
a lot more allowing the student to pick the direction
and take ownership of their own learning.
I think homeschoolers are kind of the leading edge of
this new way of thinking about learning.
Diane: Good luck to you, Rebecca.
Thanks for calling.
Here's an email going straight to the title of your book.
It's from Peter, who says, "I'm curious if you have a strategy"
"for expanding into emerging market countries,"
"which have limited Internet penetration and access to computers."
Salman: Yes. It's something that we have been thinking
and we're starting to think a lot more about.
There's a couple of things that we're doing,
and then I'll talk about the access issue.
We have had a translation project.
We've translated to varying degrees, it's 12 languages already.
The ones that are furtherest along are Spanish, Portuguese, Bengali, Arabic.
If you go to the bottom of the page on Khan Academy, there's a drop down,
it says English.
If you just pick another language, you'll see the video is translated into those languages.
There's 7,000 videos.
I shouldn't say translated, they've actually been redone
to a large degree, in a lot of these other languages.
Diane: I see.
Salman: Not the the whole, but just a video component is there.
That raises the issue, okay, even if we're creating this content,
a lot of these places, people don't have access to it.
One, there's a lot of separate groups, NGOs,
who are taking our content and putting it on DVDs,
putting it on thumb drives, creating offline versions of the website
and putting it out there.
We've heard stories.
There's an orphanage in Mongolia where some volunteers from Sysco
went out there and set it up.
There's a 15-year-old girl, Zia, out there, who started using the resource
and now she's become our main translator into Mongolian.
A 15-year-old, I think she's 16 now, orphan girl.
Diane: Wow.
Salman: That's kind of an intermediate solution.
The good thing is, now this kind of education tool can ride more as law that -
Already in India they're talking about sub $100 tablet devices,
Internet is getting cheaper and cheaper.
Even in the book I articulate essentially how right now, in the next year,
we can, if we have a couple of students sharing computers,
because we don't think kids should be on the computer all day,
even in the developing world you could deliver
this type of experience for a penny a day.
Diane: You're listening to the Diane Rehm Show.
What happens to teachers in this process?
Are you going to put them out of business?
Salman: Not at all.
It's a really good point to bring up,
because whenever people talk about a virtual thing that's scaling,
amazon.com, they're like, "Oh, that's going to replace the physical thing."
"They have to get buildings and hire people and all this stuff."
That might be true for certain things like that,
but absolutely not for education.
I think what's happening and we're seeing it with the teachers we're working with,
a lot of the adoption is happening through teachers.
They're seeing that it's not replacing them, it's empowering them.
Instead of having to shepherd students as one pace
and have this variable understanding,
they're able leverage class time for more interactivity.
I always imagine education as a spectrum of things.
At one end is very wrote learning your multiplication tables
and your vocabulary.
At the other spectrum is this kind of never ending,
open ended creative problem solving, whatever else it might be.
What Khan Academy, we're going to try to tackle
as much of the different points of the spectrum as we can,
but it's an infinite spectrum.
It frees the humans to tackle the stuff that computers will never be able to do,
the mentorship, the inspiration, the really understanding
what's going on in that particular student's life,
that particular student's brain.
The kind of stuff that Ms. Roucelle had done with me when I was in 4th grade.
Diane: Lot's of folks have asked how to spell Khan.
It is K-H-A-N, Khan Academy.
Salman: Just like Genghis.
Diane: Like Genghis.
Salman: (laughs)
Diane: kahn.org.
Salman: Maybe I shouldn't have that association.
Diane: Then, last question about evaluating teachers.
How do you think that should be done?
Salman: This is probably -
It's obviously a kind of a heated topic and frankly where I have the least experience.
I think it has to be a holistic thing.
I think it has to be a combination.
I think test will always be there, test scores will always be there
and they'll be part of a portfolio of evaluation something.
I think it goes well beyond that.
People should be measuring, how do other -
I don't even want to -
I could think of a million different ways.
One thing I point out in the book in some detail,
is be very skeptical of tests.
They are sometimes necessary to give you a data point.
They only measure 1 dimension.
A test definitely, by itself, should not be the only predictor
or only value statement on a student or a teacher.
Diane: What's next on your agenda for The Khan Academy?
Salman: We're trying to make much richer content simulations.
We're trying to broaden it, start experimenting with things in the humanities,
ways for students to answer more open-ended questions,
their opinions on stuff, how they feel about a piece of art work.
Diane: That's good.
Salman: How they feel about a piece of history.
On top of that, we're looking to open up the platform.
We have, in house, some people making hopefully great content.
There's so many people out there, teachers around the world,
who could also contribute in different ways.
We're hoping to open that in 6 months
and hopefully we just grow to a few hundred-million people in the next few years.
Diane: Salman Khan and his new book is titled The One World Schoolhouse Education Reimagined.
You can go to khanacademy.org.
Learn all about the offerings.
It is spelled K-H-A-N.
Congratulations.
Salman: Thanks for having me.
Diane: Thanks for being here.
Thanks for listening all.
I'm Diane Rehm.
(orchestra music)